[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى مناقشه ملفنا الثالث
يبدو ان زلزله تركيا احدث هزه بالمشهد
السياسي في البلاد فمنذ بدايه الكارثه
سارعت المعارضه لاتهام السلطات بالتقصير
في جهود الاغاثه كما زاد انهيارات ابنيه
كان من المفترض ان تصمد امام الزلزال زاد
من الغضب الشعبي لتسارع السلطات بفتح
تحقيق
لمقاولين واليوم والسعه السلطات التحقيق
ليشمل 612 شخصا وذلك في وقت ارتفعت فيه
حصيله الضحايا لتتجاوز الخمسين الف قتيل
في تركيا وبالجاره سوريا وزير العدل
التركي تحدث عن اعتقال 174 شخصا بتهمه
الاهمال في ملفات الابنيه مشيرا الى اصدار
مذكرات اعتقال بحق العشرات من المقاولين
ومسؤولين تفتيش الابنيه كما افادت مصادر
اعلاميه تركيا باعتقال رئيس بلديه نورداغه
التابعه وذلك بعد انهيار بنائين كان رئيس
البلديه نفسه هو المقاول المشرف على اعمال
البناء فيهما وتاتي حمله الاعتقالات في
وقت يتاهب فيه الائتلاف الحاكم والمعارضه
انتخابات من المجمع ان تجرى في مايو
المقبل وذلك وسط اتهامات متبادله بالتقصير
وباستغلال الازمه بين الطرفين
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
الدكتور سمير صالحه في الحلقه الدوليه من
اسطنبول كذلك زاهد قال رئيس وتحرير انديف
تركيا اهلا بكم
الكريمين اسمح لي ان ابدا معك استاذ زاهد
استاذ زاهد توسيع رقعه التحقيق واعتقالات
اضافيه هل تشفع للحكومه هل ترضي المعارضه
بحيث تقرا على انها خطوه ايجابيه
لمحاوله تفكيك الموضوع وايجاد حل
خاصه يعني القاء تهم على المتهمين
الحقيقيين
يعني شخصيا ابتداء اعتقد ان هذه
الاعتقالات تاتي في اطار ما يمكن تسميته
بامتصاص الغضب الكبير الموجود في الشارع
لاننا كشعب تركي ابتداء لم نتعلم من الدرس
الذي لحق بتركيا في زلزال تسعه وتسعين
ولولا الاخطاء التي تكررت في زلزال 99 لا
يمكننا الحديث عن هذه الكارثه بهذه
البشاعه الان في تركيا يعني الكثير من
المدن ما عدا ثلاث مدن رئيسيه الكثير من
المدن لا زالت الابنيه الاساسيه فيها كما
هي مثلا مدينه ديار بكر عدد المباني التي
تضررت اقل من عشر
بنايات وعدد القتلى والضحايا اكثر من 400
ونفس الرقم ينطبق على اضنه نفس الارقام
القريبه متشابهه مع في اكثر المدن التركيه
ما عدا ثلاث مدن بامكاننا ان نتحدث انها
تدمرت بالكامل وبالتالي هنا مس كبيره تقع
على عاتق الكثير من المسؤولين وليس على
المقاولين حتى لو تمت هذه الاعتقالات دعنا
نتحدث بصراحه في فتره العداله والتنميه في
فتره العشرين سنه وزلزال تسعه وتسعين كم
عدد المقاولين الذين تم اعتقالهم ما هي
اكثر محكوميه يعني في زلزال تسعه وتسعين
اكثر محكوميه او اطول محكوميه كانت سبع
سنوات لاحد المقاولين الذي كان مسؤولا عن
مبنى فيه اكثر من اربعين شخصا من الضحايا
وبالتالي في فتره العداله والتنميه لا
يوجد هناك ضحيه واحده سجنت او حبست او حكم
عليها في الزلازل السبعه والثمانيه التي
مرت في فتره العداله والتنميه وبالتالي
بغض النظر عن انتقادات المعارضه انا اعتقد
ان هناك ايمانا كبيرا في الشارع التركي
الان يطالب حقيقه ليس فقط الحكومه بل حتى
المعارضه لوضع استراتيجيه مختلفه في
التعامل مع بلد نقول انه بلد زلازل
وبالتالي حقيقه يجب هناك تغيير بالفلسفه
تغيير في كل المقاربه وليس ان ياتينا ايضا
مسؤول حكومه اليوم او الامس يقول اننا
سنبني لكم عددا جديدا من الابنيه بقدر ليس
هذا هو المطلوب بقدر
التغيير في فلسفه البناء التغيير في فلسفه
العمران التغيير في تخطيط المدن هذه هي
النقطه الاساسيه التي ينبغي ان تكون خاصه
اننا نتحدث عن تهديد كبير لا زالت تمر حتى
اسطنبول لكن المهدده
البعض بان ذلك لن يتم الا
بمتابعه الحكومه لادق التفاصيل اليوم نحن
نلاحظ رؤساء بلديات متورطون في
اشرافهم على بنايات
بعد زلزال اسقطت وبالتالي
ملفات الفساد هذه كيف ستتعامل معها
الحكومه وهنا سؤال دكتور سمير يعني ضيفي
يقول بان توسيع رقعه التحقيقات في مرحله
اولى لامتصاص الغضب الشعبي ومراقبون اخرون
كذلك يقولون بانه ان كانت هناك نيه حقيقيه
من الحكومه التركيه لملاحقه المتورطين
الحقيقيين كانت فتحت هذه الملفات في الاول
ولكن في الاول كانت اصابع الاتهام تتجه
نحو المقاولين فقط فيما بعد باحتقان
الشارع اصبحت هناك اسماء اخرى رؤساء
بلديات رؤساء اللجان فهل تلعب الحكومه
ورقه الانتخابات
مساء الخير للجميع اولا يعني انا اظن
المساله ابعد بكثير من موضوع يعني ربطها
بالانتخابات
المرتقبه في تركيا بعد ثلاث او اربعه اشهر
المساله مرتبطه بنقاش ابنيه تم تشيدها
واما انه لم يكن هناك رقابه فنيه تقنيه
قانونيه حقيقيه حول هذه الابنيه واما انه
تم تشييدها وبعد ذلك حظيت بقانون العفو
العام الاعفاءات في المخالفات مسائل
الابنيه
وغيرها من المشاريع الاعمار التي استفادت
من هذه القوانين
اسمح لي فقط ان اتفاعل معك في خصوص هذه
النقطه في داخل التركي المواطن التركي او
العايش في داخل التركي يدفع ضريبه تسمى
ضريبه حمايه من الزلزال فكيف نفسي بهكذا
قانون قانون يعطي بعض الابنيه ويمكن الناس
من شراءها او تاجيرها وهي مهدده بالسقوط
هذه مشكله حكومه
طبعا النقطه التي تتحدثين عنها مهمه واتفق
معك في ضروره ان يكون هناك شفافيه كبيره
جدا في الكشف عن هذه ارقام هذه الضرائب
وكيف صرفت واين صرفت هذه المساله لا تناقش
اطلاقا لانه مفروغ منها نقطه اساسيه مهمه
انا كنت اريد ان اقول لك غير ذلك انه ننظر
عام 1984 وفي تركيا عنا 12 قانون عفو عام
صدر عن مخالفات ابنيها هذه الاعفاءات
تعني ليس فقط حزب العداله والتنميه طالما
اننا نعود اذا حوالي 40 سنه الى الوراء
هذه الاعفاءات
مرتبطه
باحزاب سياسيه وصلت الى السلطه من اليسار
من اليمين ائتلافات حكوميه وغيرها لذلك
هذه النقاش لا يرتبط فقط بحزب العداله
والتنميه نقطه ثانيه انه نعم حزب العداله
والتنميه عنده مسؤوليه اساسيه انه تعهد
عندما جاء الى السلطه في العام
ان يتشدد في هذه المسائل مع الاسف لم نرى
هذا التشدد وهذه الممارسات من باتجاه
الملاحقه القضائيه القانونيه
التقنيه التي نتحدث عنها لذلك نعم اذا كنت
تسالين انه هل هذا هذه الازمه ستنعكس على
حزب العداله والتنميه في المرحله المقبله
في موضوع الانتخابات نعم سيكون لها
ارتدادتها شئنا ام ابينا لكن المساله ليست
مرتبطه بحزب الان في تركيا مرتبطه بتنفيذ
ماء القوانين التي تم اقراها
والمراقبات تنفيذ هذه القوانين يعني
المسائله القانونيه الان لا تكفي اشخاص
يتم اعتقالهم غدا او بعد غد يتم افراج
عنهم مثلا لابد ان يكون هناك صرامه وجديه
في اكثر من خطه وباكثر من اتجاه تبعد هذه
الكوارث عن داخل التركي
استاذ زاهد ما رايك الاعفاءات محاوله
تغيير او على الاقل اعفاء بعض المباني من
هذه الشروط
ونقاط اخرى كانت سببا في سقوط عدد هائل من
المباني مقتل الالاف
وهناك مئات الالاف مشردين هل يتحملها
الحزب الحاكم ام تعتقد كظيفه بانه ليس
المسؤول الاول او على الاقل لا يتحملها
لوحده هناك مجموعه من الظروف الاخرى
نظريا هذا الكلام صحيح بمعنى ان هناك
اطراف المعارضه واحزاب المعارضه والاحزاب
التاريخيه التركيه ايضا تتحمل الجزء جزءا
كبيرا من المسؤوليه وانا مع هذا الراي لكن
نحن نتحدث عن حزب حاكم في السلطه منذ
عشرين عاما واصدر ست قوانين اعفاء سته فقط
يعني الدكتور سمير تحدث عن 12 قانون منذ
عام 48 وفي تاريخ الجمهوريه 17 مره سته
منها في فتره العداله والتنميه والسابع
كان على الطريق في اللجنه في اللجنه
البرلمانيه لولا الزلزال كنا سنناقش
القانون السابع من هذا النوع وبالتالي
لا شك انه عشرين سنه كامله انا اعتقد كان
كفيلا كانت كفيلا هذا هذا يعني مرصد جدا
اعفاءات في 20 سنه العداله والتنميه من
ضمن 12 اعفاء منذ الاربعينات افضل من ذلك
سيدتي
صحيح والافضع من ذلك نحن نتحدث عن هذه
الاعفاءات بعد زلزال تسعه وتسعين ربما لا
اقول من باب التبرير لكن ربما من باب
الفهم للشيء استطيع ان اقول ان الاخطاء
التي ارتكبها احزاب المعارضه السياسيه قبل
عشرين سنه ربما كانت مفهومه في انه لا
يوجد هناك زلازل مدمره لكن عندما نتحدث عن
زلزال تسعه وتسعين نتحدث عن تسع مدن
وتتحدث في الارقام الرسميه عن اكثر من 18
الف قتيل ضحيه ونتحدث ربما في الارقام غير
الرسميه كما نعلم انها تجاوزت الاربعين
الفا ونتحدث عن الاف مئات الالاف من
المشردين في ذلك الوقت ومنذ ذلك الوقت
تغيرت اشياء كثيره او كان يجب حقيقه ان
يتغير في اشياء كثيره في فلسفه البناء في
فلسفه تخطيط المدن والعمران وان يتم
الاستعداد جيدا لزلزال اسطنبول المرتقب
منذ ذلك الوقت وبالتالي نحن ماذا الذي
تغير دعنا نحاسب انفسنا الشعب تركي ما
الذي تغير حقيقه منذ 99 وحتى الان يبدو
انه لم لا شيء قد تغير وبالعكس تماما هناك
تساؤل اكثر
اكثر هناك تساهل وبالتالي انا استطيع ان
اقول غالبيه التي سقطت اشكر كذلك لضيف
دكتور سمير صالحه في العلاقات الدوليه
شكرا جزيلا لكما والله يحمي الجميع
شكرا على المتابعه والسلام عليكم